welcome back everyone this is going to
be my attack on titan season 4 episode 8
video
assassins bullet there's so much stuff
happening we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to my channel i'm
doing videos for all the attack on titan
season 4 episodes be sure to subscribe
to get everything
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the episode yet because we'll be
talking about everything and i'll just
number these as we go along through wtf
moments and easter eggs
just starting with the title of the
episode assassin's bullet
obviously a reference to gabby braun
sniping sasha with her gun
is the survey core and the rest of the
ld and attack team were taking off in
the airship
everyone press f in the chat to pay
respects to the best potato girl who
ever lived
don't worry we'll talk about sasha
because her death will have waves that
will affect
all the other characters for the next
big arc of the series so we're sort of
transitioning from the marley arc of the
manga to the war for paradise arc that
is the final arc of the story i know
everyone's freaking out because there
are only 16 episodes listed on the wiki
for attack on titan right now
but there's no way that they could
speedrun the rest of the story in the
amount of episodes that are listed on
the wiki right now so they'll probably
be
a season 4 part 2 like a second core of
episodes
but the episode starts right where
episode 7 left off with reiner having
completely regenerated himself well
maybe not completely but regenerated
himself into another armored titan to
join the fight
not because he was trying to save the
rest of the marlins as gabby and falco
thought
screaming their lungs out at him but
because he was still kind of hoping for
the chance just a small chance that if
he were to fight aaron jaeger again
aaron might kill him and end his
suffering and that would free him of his
guilty conscience over everything that
he'd done while he was on parodies
all the people that they killed all
their friends that were hurt when they
took down the first ball then everything
that came after
and this has a lot to do with what was
going on with reiner's titan because
i've seen a lot of people asking why his
armor tightened and this scene looks
so different from its normal look the
armor plating doesn't cover his entire
body his face looks more like a normal
face without the standard plating
covering it
so it's like he's entering battle with
half of his armor on
when you think about the line of
dialogue that he went out on during
episode 7
that should give you a clue as to why he
looks like this
he purposefully stopped his titan
transformation before it completely
covered him in arbor plating
because he wanted to leave himself
exposed he wanted to give aaron more of
a chance at killing him in battle
in fact he's not even trying here aaron
pretty much one shots him
even though he's able to grab porco's
jaw titan from him
but i love that aaron is still post
nutcracker incident with porco's jaw
titan
and it hasn't had time to regenerate its
limbs so he's swinging it around like
some
kind of titan club like he's carrying it
into battle while he's fighting
there's some more creative use of titans
for you and even though he's just drank
that warhammer titan milkshake he's
gained the full power of that titan
so he does learn new titan powers pretty
quickly but it's still
going to take him a hot minute to learn
how to fully integrate the warhammer
titan abilities
into his other abilities as the attack
titan and the founding titan
more to that too reiner showing up
stopped him short before he could take
the power of the jaw titan
so right now as it stands after the
battle porco is still the jaw titan
but after he grabs the jaw titan and
aaron one shots him
aaron stops short in his tracks claiming
that he doesn't have the energy to
finish reiner off they kind of
referenced this earlier so it's possible
that he's being
truthful but there's no malice on his
face when he's talking about it to
mikasa so it's possible here that he
also chose not to push himself to finish
off reiner
because he didn't want to kill him like
he told him in episode five he doesn't
want to destroy him anymore so in here
he's just using the energy limit as an
excuse to do that to walk away
then as the survey corps the aliens take
off in the airship gabby just
hits fever pitch and rushes after them
with her rifle trying to take all of
them down by herself
falco chases her down and obviously this
is the biggest part of the episode this
big emotional arc that they're on
like they hype up the aaron versus
reiner fight so much in last week's
episode
gabby and falco are like oh you're gonna
get it now the armored titan writer's
gonna kick your butt so bad but the
battle is over so quickly that they're
like wait what what just happened
like aaron vs reiner is the smallest
part of the episode they blow past it so
quickly
love the look on armin's face as he
greets aaron and mikasa returning to the
ship
they share that exchange the two of them
and there's so much weight in the looks
that they give each other armin still
horrified by everything he just did in
the bay destroying everything like he
went off like a nuclear bomb when he
transformed into the colossal titan
and he's so conflicted by everything
that aaron had done to force their hand
all this death and the collateral damage
but he still really cares about aaron
just like mikasa does but then of course
levi
shows up and starts throwing insults at
aaron and you kind of snap back to
reality like oh yeah
everyone is super pissed at aaron not
just the marlians but all the eldians as
well
the show has kind of set him up as the
new big bad of the series the past few
episodes the big villain that everyone
hates
and everyone that's calling him a
villain technically is not wrong
everything that willie tiber said in his
final speech about aaron unleashing the
rumbling
activating the thousands of colossal
titans that make up the walls of
parodies and destroying the world
all that's not wrong aaron at least as
far as we know right now still plans to
do that so it's kind of like
everyone everyone around the world
versus aaron at this point the enemy of
humanity
but in this moment as they all sort of
reunite he still has a few
friends and he's such a high value
weapon two parodies that they're kind of
forced to work with him
if he were not the founding titan though
or even the attack titan they probably
would have just executed him on spot for
what he did
and that's also why armin stops mikasa
from intervening when levi starts
smacking aaron around and they formally
arrest him he's like no this needs to
happen
aaron needs to answer for his crimes
even though nobody here is enjoying this
although it seems kind of like levi is
enjoying smacking him around a little
bit
the only person that levi enjoys
smacking around more than aaron is
zeke so we'll talk about that in a
second too when levi says aaron has some
explaining to do
i don't really expect aaron to be very
forthcoming beyond what he already wrote
in his letters that's pretty much what
he tells him like it's all in there in
the letters that i sent you
i've already explained myself very
clearly even though we as the audience
didn't get to read any of those letters
the reaction on his face is amazing too
like aaron doesn't even register any
kind of reaction or visible emotion
because he's so
committed to his course of action in the
rumbling then as the rest of their
forces start to board the airship they
start celebrating sasha talks about the
six soldiers they lost
they start going on about how they're
gonna rebuild the eldian empire after
the great titan war take back everything
that was taken from them
which also kind of foreshadows the big
twist anytime they're celebrating before
they've actually left the battlefield
you know something big
is happening there's going to be some
twist that'll take it back but then she
cuts the tension talking about more food
this is obviously just setting up the
big twist in her final words talking
about food talking about meat
then we go back to gabby and falco and
obviously she's not having
any of what falco is trying to sell her
on she remembers sophia getting crushed
during aaron's attack then udo getting
trampled to death
by the panicking crowd while he was
trying to save her the marlian guards
that then
also tried to save her and were killed
by a woman on the rooftop
that woman was sasha obviously also
setting up the big twist with her
killing sasha in a little bit
they also still think that zeke is dead
at this point in the story so they're
completely demoralized
so all this anger that she's feeling
over the deaths of her friends
and her sympathy with the marlians now
renewed sympathy because the soldiers
tried to save her
is coalescing into this perfect storm
turning her into a marly stan
even though her whole life she's been
fed all this rhetoric and lies about the
eldians
by the marlians she's on the fast train
to crazytown she wants to wipe all the
aldians off the map
but she kind of explains where she's
coming from and she was not there for
any of the aaron reiner conversation
that falco saw so falco is kind of doing
the slow work
in the next arc of the series trying to
get her to come around on the whole
notion of war
and killing her own people because she's
an aldian just like them
as falco was explaining this to gabby
you kind of have to laugh at her
reaction to this she kind of calls
fake news on him like were you there for
that did you see that happen
no i didn't see it happen so her brain
has gone so crazy town that she's kind
of pretending like it's not a thing like
i
i don't think that that's a thing i
don't think that they killed all those
people when clearly that all happened
like we all saw it play out over the
first couple seasons of the show
she's able to hit one of their soldiers
but because he's still attached to the
3d maneuvering cable anchored to the
airship
she uses it to go full leeroy jenkins on
the entire airship
falco unsuccessfully trying to stop her
winding up going along for the ride just
remembering reiner's last conversation
with him
you need to save gabby but gaby and
falcao are able to get on the ship
getting a shot off on sasha before
everyone realizes what's happening
and she doesn't die immediately but she
does go out on such a great line
asking where her dinner is in her actual
last word being meat
obviously big callback to her on the
wall as aaron remembers her at the end
of the episode
laughing and crying at the same time the
whole weight of sasha's death is going
to hang over the next arc of the series
in a really
important way so her death will inform
some really important actions from her
friends and these other characters that
are all tied up in this
gabby and falco's arc in particular it's
just that it's going to take gabby
a long long time to get to that place
mentally but it kind of starts when you
see the other aldean soldiers
show them mercy like do we want to throw
them right out the hatch and just dash
their bodies on the rocks no
when does the killing stop they hate all
this as much as falco remembers reiner
hating it so falco's sort of realizing
this connecting all the dots in his head
like wait a minute they're just like us
but back on marley we see peak healing
up none the worst for wear and magath
trying to pick up the pieces tracking
down all the other titan warriors like
reiner
pique starts recalling the strange
marley and soldier that tricked them
into the pit earlier that's yelena
she's one of zeke's confederates inside
the marlin army you learn a little bit
about her during this episode but
they'll continue to reveal more about
her in the next couple of episodes
it's not so much that she loves parodies
and she wants to see them burn marley to
the ground or anything like that
she's just a zeke stan through and
through
as we'll continue to see her character
is a good example a good template for
the idea of zella tree
like who are the good guys in all this
when the supposed forces of the
protagonists
aaron and the other aldians are doing
things that are just as horrific
and underhanded as what the marlians
have been doing this whole time
it's another example of what they've
been trying to convey through this
entire marley arc of the series
that everyone is the same there are no
winners in this war only losers
and both sides are to blame both sides
are just as bad as the other
except for aaron yeager he's kind of
like the s-tier bad guy of the moment
right now
then i love this gabby and falco
reversal as they reveal what was going
on with zeke the whole time
she's screaming about making them pay
for killing zeke and they're like
hold that thought you can tell him all
about it yourself when we show you and
you open the door and they see him
sitting there regenerating his limbs
hanji steps out talking to zeke about
the whole plan how it all went down
revealing to gabby and falco that zeke
was in on this
the whole time he was behind this big
attack the miscalculations that zeke is
talking about obviously
are gabby and falco winding up on board
that was not planned as well as peak and
porco escaping the trap
and were able to intervene during the
battle resulting in more parodies
casualties
and levi's conversation with zeke should
make it pretty clear where they stand
with each other
levi still very much wants to kill him
but is forced to work with him for the
greater cause of defeating the marlians
in the moment
and zeke doesn't really care about levi
at all he's just using him to achieve
his plan
of wielding the power of the founding
titan through aaron he really only cares
about aaron and the founding titan
because they're so critical to his plan
the paradise eldians are really just a
means to an end for him he doesn't
really care about them either like he
talks about freeing eldians all over the
world
and he does kind of want to do that but
he has zero remorse over the idea that
so
many people are going to have to die
before this plan comes to fruition
then aaron reminds us the whole reason
for the surprise attack destroying the
fleet their command structure just
to delay the inevitable all-out war for
parodies
that's the title of the final arc of the
manga story the war for parodies that's
what we're heading into right now
so it's coming obviously it's just that
it's gonna take maga time to rebuild
their ships so that they can actually
bring the marlians to parodies to have
the war itself
i love the little joke that hanji gets
out about referencing saving aaron all
the time there's always somebody that
has to come
save you which isn't wrong usually it's
mikasa that always winds up having to
save him it's just that this time in
particular it was extra crazy
because of the circumstances aaron
forcing their hand into battle
purposely making himself a hostage then
just as zeke is trying to remind them
that this is not all in vain they reveal
sasha has
died everyone has their own level of
reaction based on how close they were
to sasha but they're all pissed and even
aaron like i said is saddened by he
starts crying and getting really broken
up about it remembering
that her final word was meat thinking
back about the time she stole the meat
from the officer's mess
trying to share it with all them so even
though he seemed like a monster during
this past arc
it shows that he's not a total
psychopath just a little bit of a
psychopath
but the voice you hear speaking over the
trailer for episode 9 is yell in his
voice talking about how they
may have been able to find some other
way of achieving their goals without all
the bloodshed
but what's done is done there's nothing
we can do about it we see the flashback
of sasha eating seafood for the first
time cooked by one of the marlin
soldiers
freaking out because she loves it so
much then them burying her body
in hanji making more plans so my episode
9 video we'll post next sunday
just like normal but if you spotted any
more big references or easter eggs
during episode 8 that i didn't mention
in the video just write them below in
the comments
everyone click here for all my attack on
titan season 4 episodes
and click here for that brand new one
division episode 5 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and think about
sasha when you eat dinner tonight
you